pourquoi est ce qu'on parle de la
frontière parce qu'ils n'ont évidemment
cdt des gens traversent la frontière ils
veulent aller faire leurs achats visiter
leurs cousins leurs cousines et puis
faire des provisions d'ordinaire
exactement il ya aussi cuit parce que de
l'autre côté il ya nouvelles sont très
peu rassurante
tous ces haïtiens qui arrivent en masse
là il n'y a pas que la traversée d'un
côté on a des gens qui viennent des
états unis parce qu'ils ont peur d'être
rapatriés dans leur pays d'origine il y
avait beaucoup de nouvelles cette
semaine à ce sujet il y avait beaucoup
de nouvelles beaucoup de ces gens qui
arrivaient avec des bébés sur le dos qui
malheureusement devait passer par le
stade olympique pour un premier tri on
premier prix avant d'être inséré dans de
nouveaux logements
oui alors c'est maintenant dans la tribu
si bon qu'il y avait le stade olympique
ça c'était la semaine dernière vendredi
on apprenait cette semaine on a appris
qu'il fallait réquisitionné d'autres
édifices édifice pour pouvoir placer ces
gens qui fuient les états unis dans le
train mais maintenant il a été construit
l'armée canadienne a été appelé en
rescousse si vous voulez à la frontière
pourrait diriger certains je veux dire
des tentes provisoires pour accueillir
ces personnes là qui arrive vraiment par
centaines
on parle de grappes de personnes qui
fuient c'est une première la vie faut
bien que la croix rouge est très très
active sur le terrain et quelques jours
on va donner des images ces mille mots
mais on va redonner plusieurs donc on
aura un million non à vous proposer
en l'espace d'une minute à peine vous
allez voir à quoi se ressent
présentement à la frontière américaine
au canada c'est notre première vidéo
quelques minutes après une autre voiture
rendu cette fois ci ils sont 7 et le nom
je suis finalement aucune crainte
vis-à-vis des nombreux d'agents qui les
a tant apporté à ces téléphones
cellulaires 16h30
nouvel arrivé trois personnes puis à 18
heures du nouveau taxi agent évalue le
groupe a pris d'une vingtaine bruit
pourquoi
une problème il ya des problèmes aux
etats-unis cette dame en créole le
président il n'acceptait pas de nous
donner des pâtis depuis quelques
semaines le point de passage est
littéralement filiation en fait un
véritable vent de panique s'est emparée
des communautés haïtiennes aux états
unis et qui suit en ce moment les états
unis alors ça c'est un écho de la crise
humanitaire on va revenir cette non au
cours des prochaines semaines c'est ça
fait partie de l'actualité canadienne
mais évidemment il ya la réalité
estivale
nous on passe la même frontière pour
profiter des deux ce qui reste des
vacances d'été je fais un tour de table
ici l'aspect plus ludique de notre
conversation jour d'arrivée 1
avez vous déjà eu peur en traversant la
frontière vers les états unis
marie-claude peut-être quelques reprises
des angoisses comme par exemple j'étais
allé faire un reportage à bostens sur un
navire de guerre qui j'avais de la
poudre explosive sur les lorsqu'on a
fait des démonstrations
puis je n'avais pas d'influx de tête est
interceptée à cause de ça à la frontière
quand j'avais une lettre quand même de
l'armée canadienne mais même à ça je
voulais pas trop rentrer dans ce
donc je ne veux pas vraiment de bon non
non non il n'y en a même pas mais je
sais que j'avais de la méthode
si vous voulez on vous a déjà interviewé
comme ça gentiment oui oui qui fêtait
avec mon accent monde drôle d'accent
toujours libres ces questions mais là la
pire ça a été je avant d'avoir la
citoyenneté canadien moi j'avais le dis
ça pour les états unis mais j'ai eu de
la stérilité je demandais comment
s'appelle le passe pas oui je passe avec
les passeports et m'a dit vous avez du
document officiel pourquoi c'est pas moi
je viens d'avoir mon passeport canadien
je sais pas pourquoi ils ont pas être
assez l'autre il va falloir que vous
communiquez avec mais c'est pas moi
c'est vous qui a fait l'erreur
vous mentez nisme vous en train d'avoir
des documents cas moi je les officiers
le canadien ah oui puis on était un
trentaine de minutes en train de
discuter sur pied discute pas très
gentiment et déjà qu'ils en arrivent on
vous avez connu on vous offre carrément
faire fermer les pâtons états unis on
m'a retourné au canada
en fait je passais souvent la frontière
parce que j'habitais dans le sud de
l'ontario à windsor donc la ville de
touba est tout juste en face alors je
pense que trois quatre fois par semaine
je traversais la frontière
et puis un jour j'ai été légèrement
impertinente mais le temps du douanier
m'agaçait et là j'ai eu et dixon ne
parlait pas l'anglais
ça fait envie de m'amuser mais il n'a
pas trouvé ça drôle alors il m'a
retourné au canada mais finalement
puisque à windsor ya il ya deux passages
j'ai emprunté le passage le même jour
oui le même jour ils n'ont pas vérifié
il n'y a pas eu de communication entre
les deux postes frontières donc je fais
exactement ces violences mais c'est vrai
que mais ils sont pas facile n'est-ce
pas et des fois ça devient un petit peu
agaçant commence à s'énerver alors cette
journée là il n'avait pas été
sympathique comme je me suis dit non il
n'y a pas de communication entre nous il
y en aura encore moins alors voilà je ne
m'adresse à vous en anglais chez moi je
parle de la frontière au moins une fois
par année l'été en général j'étais avec
des amis c'était au mois de juin
et puis il coupe bien gentils ils sont
fait carrément mettre de côté en 30
minutes reçu refus d'entrée le copain
avait fait un délit dans un magasin
avant le vol et on ne désire pas de
danger peut prendre ce poste frontière
tout petit alors que lui a pas de
problème qu'il pose pas de questions ça
a changé maintenant sous trempe l'an
dernier s'il n'y avait pas de problème
les appareils et ont scanné mon
passeport mais il regarde il prenait des
feuilles les empreintes digitales
j'étais vraiment équipé comme je voyage
ou alors c'est le monde change eric
c'est que dès qu'on arrive dans ce sens
tout comme des criminels n'avoir rien
sans frontières et généralement ils vont
scanner votre corps reçoit les voix si
vous cachez pas dangereux et toutes
sortes de fouilles vraiment avec les
questions les enjeux et des
la france et les eau se préoccupait y
faisait peut-être de mon accent mon
accent je peux messager québécois mais
les québécois pure laine blanc doit ce
n'est pas vous c'est pas de la peur
c'est de l'endroit bien plus ils
demandent des questions bizarres et ce
qui vaut pour les armes
tiens on dit non il ne peut pas être en
train de me poser ces questions-là
pionne doute pourquoi vous douté parce
qu'ils se sont effondrés la bonne
réponse immédiat c'est comme une seconde
utilise choses auraient été plus loin
oui alors quand on vous demande s'il a
un casier judiciaire vous répondez oui
non mais non goûter voici deux québécois
pure laine comme on dit l'expression
québécoise aux autres ils ont peut-être
passé et ça s'est terminé par une
fouille de dix minutes voici l'incident
vidéo nuire aux deux de la journée
[Musique]
quand même
le groupe de chicago
on a manqué de rigueur
[Musique]
damas
ils ont été fouillés c'est parce
qu'apparemment ils travaillent ils
craignaient que cet individu qui puisse
travailler comme ça sur internet à
distance se rendent aux états unis pour
y effectuer du travail c'est l'une des
choses qui seraient des temps c'est ça
demain alors lorsque vous rendez d'abord
sait jamais pour des faut faire
attention à ce qu'on déclare maintenant
heureux vous pensez que c'est juste les
canadiens qui ont des sueurs froides en
traversant la frontière
imaginez des américains qui revient de
chez eux qui ont été refoulés par les
douaniers canadiens que par ils
n'avaient pas de document n'avait pas
valeur canada n'y a pas de problème
c'est déjà très sympathique
alors j'ai trouvé ça sur internet
j'ai traduit en français ce que disait
le douanier ici et les devoirs le change
et d'autres lake s'adresse à des
américains sur un document dans le taux
de jeunes fous comme ça qu'ils filment
eux aussi leur mésaventure à la douane
aux frontières voici ce que ça donne
[Musique]
ce sens
nous avons la mère de stéphane hains il
faut comprendre les douaniers américains
on est dans un contexte de plus en plus
difficile avec le terrorisme
international qui prend de l'ampleur les
attentats du 11 septembre on nous on est
loin de les avoir oubliés dont quelque
part cette levée de boucliers aux
frontières il faut cibler comprendre ça
rigole ça nous mène à notre question tam
tam de la semaine sans que ces questions
je n'ai pas tué je peux vous aimons
partager merde comme ça alors problème à
la frontière hébergés dans nos aéroports
les douaniers canadiens ou américains
ont-ils trop de pouvoirs ou pas assez
anodin mais ils vont commencer par vous
pour pouvoir vous pas eu ni l'un ni
l'autre en fait je pense qu'ils ont
suffisamment de pouvoir
on le voit justement avec les vidéos
qu'on vient de présenter je pense qu'ils
ont tous les pouvoirs nécessaires pour
agir en conséquence et alice a raison
c'est une question d'en faire aux
sections l'adapei la question de la
sécurité nationale dans les faits un
enjeu sur lequel on ne badine pas les
douaniers aux frontières que ce soit de
l'autre côté
comme ici doivent véritablement jouer
leur rôle pour assurer la sécurité des
citoyens d'un bon sens de l'engagement
états unis une super puissance toujours
ciblé toujours donc c'est vrai
aujourd'hui attention le terrorisme ne
reconnaît pas la superpuissance on soit
petit ou grand tout le monde est visé
donc comme je le disais tantôt d'un côté
comme de l'autre il faut que les
frontières et les douaniers joue
effectivement leur rôle les autres
pouvoirs ou pas assez pour moi il en
1 les pouvoirs qu'il faut mais il
démontre plus une question d'attitude
entre eux ils veulent démontrer comme
moi je suis l'autorité toi tu dois faire
c'est que je veux je sais pas s'ils
peuvent le faire mais ils les font ils
démontrent que les autorités
que ce soit dans douaniers américains
vous pensez que les douaniers canadiens
jouent si on monte le temps moi ça fait
quelques mois je te raconte par la colle
là la petite entrée il ya un seul vous
sniffer de la colle au nom et s'appelle
l'accord puis c'était deux jours mais on
avait été trois jours aux etats-unis ont
révélé des boston avec ma famille et moi
ma femme et ses trois enfants mais - qui
on avait acheté une bouteille de vin
kimasi et comment ce que je sais que
vous étiez plus de deux jours à boston
mais là c'est votre ordinateur
sinon j'ai besoin de dieu reçu ni reçu
d'aidé de jeu par exemple de développer
l immensité commun comme un bon ok je te
montre est mon téléphone et j'ai montré
les téléphones mais la prochaine fois
imprimé somme c'est ça le problème
ils demandent des choses et on ne sait
pas parce que c'est sûr que des fois ils
en sont un peu trop rêveur reçu tous les
sens je pense qu'en général ça aide à
documenter le passé donc un conseil pour
chaque prochaine fois quand même soin et
soyez avec vos papiers peints sans
papiers sales est stable l'idée n'a
remis en arabe et tous les petits
détails ont reçu les différentes
factures et je suis étonné du de la
description que vous faites du doigt me
canadien parce que l'été dernier je suis
allé aux états unis cherchaient de
l'insecticide naturel sans l'ingrédient
c'est pendant du canada tranche d'un
gardien chimiques chez walmart
une trentaine de kilomètres de chez moi
on m'a accusé deux fois d'être un
criminel à la frontière j'ai quand même
passé sur ce passé à travers et en zone
non on m'a demandé de ne pas regarder
très sympathique et au mondial et
combien là vous n'êtes pas seul à 12 ans
n'importe quoi des caleçons et puis
voici à quoi ça ressemblait voici une
autre aussi typique moi je pensais
c'était c'était l'expérience de tout le
monde
[Musique]
alors voilà qui va se passer je pense
excité vous dans la vidéo l'audio c'est
mon histoire mon expérience est vécue
par d'autres personnes c'est la nouvelle
expérience
je voulais vous demander si j'ai un
autre le jeu questionnaire aujourd'hui
c'est que chantal avait été la
championne et vous rattachez tous et
avant qu'enfin ce jeu de ce rallye où
est le problème technique
quand même bien de vente et on sent
qu'on me démoraliser douaniers en
n'étant pas nous
les modulations de tendance est sans
souci voici le jeu questionnaire la plus
petite frontière commune entre deux pays
c'est où exactement entre qu'elle payait
quel petit tiens tiens
c'est tellement petit
ça passe inaperçu peut-être ont-ils de
guinée entre les deux guinée en afrique
guinée conakry c'est très souvent on
parle d'à peine un kilomètre co2/km
l'espagne et le portugal
ah non la règle d'or
les palois qui est d'accrocher l'espagne
volés par les grandes l'es10 plus tentés
de pays depuis un bon bout de temps
james bond on a filmé un film dessus de
ça gibraltar le détrousser vie qui gagne
d'être au mythe il insisté je savais
très 200 m
oui encore plus de pierre parrat miles
moi je vois pas comment c'est passé
entre le botswana et la zambie en
afrique 0,6 cent cinquante mètres la
france va connaître samedi
de quoi mettre au moins deux gros
douaniers américains les bains on
apprend alors est-ce que tout va bien
techniquement pour la présentation de m
dernier arrivé c'est qu'est ce qui te
prend même la caméra n'a plus une caméra
ça va bien non pas trop proches s'il
vous plaît oui c'est parce que on avait
dit qu'on avait les secrets ou comment
passer la frontière sans tapis et même ô
sans-papiers matériel mais vous ne
pouvez pas vous arrêter à l'élève doit
de passer mais sans vous arrêter à
vanter à la frontière du québec avec une
petite ville j'ai trouvé ça s'était mise
en ligne cette semaine par un français
qu'un touriste français qui vient à qui
passer chez nous et pour montrer à
dresde apprennent comment s'y prendre je
pense que vous pourriez arrêtez monsieur
pas ce qui va se passer si vous un
moment où le trier et vous entraînera
une raison cette semaine de dire que la
frontière est devenu une passoire et oui
il à faire vous pouvez le dire voyez la
vidéo pour qu'il mette soldats l'épreuve
finale
aujourd'hui nous sommes arrivés vers de
prendre mon petit déjeuner je vais
prendre la moitié à celui des cendres à
la frontière on était passé la frontière
sans présenter le moindre papier tu sais
pas comment tu es je te conseille très
fortement de regarder la suite de la
vidéo
allez c'est parti go
[Musique]
et
sur l'instinct est dans le sud du québec
à la frontière avec burning qui se
tombent dans le vermont aux états unis
on va démontrer
voilà l'ennemi après le virage tout ce
qui se trouve à ma gauche
se trouvera donc aux yeux et tard tout
ce qui se trouve à ma droite se trouve
au canada
c'est la particularité de tête de cette
route
et la frontière est vraiment au niveau
de la ligne jaune que vous croyez qu'on
sente
marquer l'arrêt
la frontière oui les postes frontières
qu'aux frontières américains à gauche au
poste-frontière canadien badoit
donc ça c'est la particularité
quand vous circulez
des temps - vous trouvez au canada ont
découvert tout le monde savait qu'il ya
des petits villages justement ce imagine
dans le coin de stanstead
la maison étant paru aux états
effectivement donc les gens vivent
seulement dans les deux pays de sault
d'étoilés lançant sur les bases et le
lie au canada le tranquille où les pieds
et les pieds du nid aux états unis puis
la tête au canada mais pourquoi pas
aller à ma mère m'a dit tu explores tout
je découvre tout et ils viennent nous
montrer comme ça on joue la montre oui
mais non c'est ça il y avait eu des des
reportages même dans dans les journaux
ici sur sur ces villages là partagé
entre deux pays
mais ces gens là sont de plus en plus
embêté parce que comme évidemment il ya
une surveillance accrue si c'est tout
temps on passe on passe son temps à leur
demander leurs papiers ça devient de
plus en plus compliqué les routes alors
voilà on se quitte là dessus
moi je m'en avait passé à la frontière
c'est un peu mitigé
oui j'ai à faire c'est un contrat qui
ont fait rentrer deux provinces dans
votre cas
peut-être à chaque fois j'ai passé trop
cher là là je me dis un jour ancêtres
avoir douaniers qui pourrait paraître
hautaine je reste au canada pour le
moment mais peut-être qu'un jour pour
changer alors c'est le même les noeuds
des ce que vous quitterez bientôt plus
ben oui non comme base une heure à peu
près
il nous quitte mais je veux revenir la
semaine prochaine s'ils voulaient
revenir c'est votre choix aussi bien
avec moi à la volée sais pas je ne vous
suivrai pas qu'ils aient tous sans
papiers là toi tu m'en soucie ciel puis
tenté de traverser l'association
d'obtenir beaucoup d'émotion aujourd'hui
beaucoup trop d'émotion alors beaucoup
de revenus cette semaine chez sage c'est
moi qui vous remercie de m'avoir invité
à venir quand vous voulez votre émission
à la n'arrivons jamais juste un dernier
commentaire avant de vous quitter pour
l'emoa par exemple n'y a pas de
frontières qu'on soit au canada ou aux
états unis les communautés mohawks ans
sur leurs terres sont ni au canada ni
aux états unis mais sont sur leur
territoire le territoire était divisé un
jour par une frontière alors ils
montrent leurs passeports mois que ils
ont pu soit mais normalement il m'a en
fait tu passes par match plein marasme
et de documents oui mais en réalité pour
eux il n'y a pas de frontier apporte par
les conservateurs a pareillement aux
occupants il faut choisir un vrai
reportage un jour là de soutien plus
loin qu'ils vont pouvoir insérer comment
se déroulent les placer pour être
merveilleux marie claude a maintenant
prochaine wachel logis mais nos
fantastiques merci pour les erreurs
techniques